we begin tonight with another huge
bombshell dropped by the new york times
america has a free speech problem hmm
go on
americans are losing hold of a
fundamental right as citizens of a free
country the right to speak their minds
and voice their opinions in public
without fear of being shamed or shunned
something is definitely happening here
in america
a full article from the new york times
more than like 2500 words blasting
liberal hypocrites for shutting down the
people they disagree with
here's another quote
you can't consider yourself a supporter
of free speech and be policing and
punishing speech more than protecting it
free speech demands a greater
willingness to engage with ideas we
dislike
so if canceled culture is confirmed
just like hunter's laptop the newspaper
of record says so
so it has to be true
and this comes 24 hours after the times
authenticated hunter biden's laptop from
hell confirming what we knew all along
that hunter raked in three and a half
million from the mayor of moscow's
family
that he was bribed with a three-carat
diamond from a sketchy chinese communist
and joe biden indeed is the big guy
no matter what he says
it's just what it is it's a smear
campaign i have no response it's another
smear campaign but this he's accusing me
of is a russian plan
they have said that this is has all the
care four five former heads of the c.i.a
both parties say what he's saying is a
bunch of garbage
so is it time for all of the media who
soiled themselves for the biden campaign
to apologize
i think it's this i think it's one of
the biggest scandals i've ever seen and
you don't cover it
you want to talk about it well because
it can't be verified you want to talk
about insignificant things i'm telling
you of course it can be verified excuse
me they found the laptop leslie listen
what can't be verified the laptop
so now that it's been verified have
these journalists had a change of heart
well katherine herridge tried this
morning
you said earlier this is a document
driven case
what do we know about the documents
involved in this ongoing investigation
well we have some insight here at cbs
news and we were able to obtain records
that we believe came from hunter biden's
laptop we had these records in late 2020
and they do raise some significant
questions about his tax strategy there's
no sign of
at least publicly of any political
interference not that we're suggesting
there has been any but
maybe catherine will get a piece on 60
minutes this weekend
probably not
because 24 hours after the times dropped
the bomb on hunter
almost nobody's touched the story
they're all just following the official
white house line
my question about the conflict of
interest when it comes to china is last
year the first son's attorney said that
he divested from a chinese investment
fund controlled by chinese state-owned
entities we have received not even basic
transparency about who bought out his
stake when this happened and how much
money changed hands did he actually
divest and if so can you agree to the
private citizen he doesn't work for the
government i'd point you to his
representatives thank you elders i think
we're done here thank you very much go
ahead oh temper temper jen
nobody's interested in this times big
scoop
similar situation with this cancel
culture story that i just told you about
the times is getting raked over the
kohl's for publishing that today here
are the headlines
this free speech take is staggering in
its dishonesty
readers blast new york times for
appalling claims it makes about free
speech
the new york times editorial board
should retract and resign
keith olbermann you remember that guy
well he's furious
he says here there is not freedom to
have any opinion without consequences
according to olbermann opinions are the
real crime wave
we never thought we'd see this but
liberal pundits and journalists across
the country today
savaging the times and demanding the
resignations of everybody on the
editorial board
they want to cancel the new york times
for writing canceled culture doesn't
exist
or does
no
you better retract or you're canceled
quote
it's hard to imagine a more fundamental
misreading of the freedom of speech or
an organization whose credibility
depends more on
understanding it correctly than today's
lead editorial from the new york times
editorial board here's my solution
correct this editorial and resign
welcome to my world new york times
welcome to all of our worlds
now you know what it feels like when you
tell the truth in america
telling the truth has become the most
dangerous thing you can do in the united
states
you can hurt people and get bailed out
you can lie and win a pulitzer
you can cover up the truth and win an
election but if you tell the truth
you can lose everything your livelihood
your reputation everything
maybe the new york times finally
realized being in the business of lying
isn't good for business
you know especially as a newspaper
maybe they'll tell the truth about dr
fauci now
maybe they'll tell the truth about the
border
maybe
maybe they'll tell the truth about the
difference
between men and women maybe and maybe
they might even start saying merry
christmas hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else